Luc Besson m'a permis d'acheter un
appartement
à Boulogne en face du bois que j'ai tout
cassé le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui a dit donc c'est une star de
téléréalité elle a dit qu'il lui fallait
35000 € par mois minimum pour vivre
sinon
forcément elle s'en sort pas parce que
avec le prix de l'essence quoi je trouve
que c'est pas audible aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui sont vraiment dans le
besoin le 10 du mois c'est très
compliqué on parle de l'électricité on
parle des boulangers qui a qui doivent
mettre la clé sous la porte etc et tu as
une jeune femme qui dit et moi j'ai
besoin de 35000 dis on n'est pas
d'accord alors moi ce qui me choque le
plus c'est qu'elle est kiffe choqué
c'est hoer déjà et ensuite au delà de ça
c'est que ces gens là c'est leur seul
fond de commerce et tout ce qu'ils ont à
dire c'est je suis riche je suis blindé
j'habite à Dubaï et je vous emmerde
c'est un manque de respect pour les gens
qui les suivent qui ont pas beaucoup
d'argent et en fait c'est encore une
fois la culture du rien et ce serait
bien qu'on donne la parole en 2023 des
gens qui ont des choses à dire et pas
des gens qui n'ont rien à dire en fait
on demande en avant des gens
ça va presque c'est pas une maladresse
de sa part est-ce qu'elle avait dit non
elle a fait exprès de répondre à ça
parce qu'ils adorent ils font que ça
toute seule
elle est suivie par des millions de
personnes donc si les gens se
désabonnent d'elle en fait les gens sont
d'accord
si tu trouves ça m'agace les hypocrisies
de Guillaume surtout quand on connaît ta
vie enfin pardon mais à donner la parole
à deux intelligents elle l'a volé son
argent non elle l'a gagné elle en fait
ce qu'elle veut la réponse de faire
chier les gens qui gagnent du pognon
elle l'a gagné comment il gagne
si tu as réussi tu as réussi qu'est-ce
que ça peut te [ __ ] tu trouves que
c'est plus intelligent que tu fais si
c'est pas j'ai j'ai pas cette prévention
là j'ai juste que c'est juste que gagner
de l'argent en faisant des placements de
produits
économie bidon il foireuse pour des des
trucs de paris sportifs bidon que tout
le monde connaît
des abonnés qui ont pas un rond je
trouve ça pas très important
ici il y en a 15000 qui crèvent de faim
donc c'est à dire qu'elle est plus haut
que les autres de faire chier les gens
c'est
[Musique]
déjà première question qui est Miss
France
[Applaudissements]
tu veux gagner on le sent pas vraiment
parce qu'il y a toujours de la
concurrence c'est vrai que nous aussi
voilà non mais c'est vrai qu'on sait
dans l'aventure il y a des favoris et
après enfin c'est s'amuser à en profit
du moment où on ne pense pas vraiment à
tout ça pourquoi vous avez voulu vous
présenter à Miss France comment est-ce
que c'est des gens qui vous disent ouais
tu es magnifique il faut que tu fasses
Miss France merci aux parents c'est qui
c'est longue histoire alors c'est déjà
par rapport à ma mère parce que c'était
présenté à l'élection de mille fois
loupe exactement 98 elle avait été lu
première dauphine et en fait elle a
gardé tous les souvenirs de son de son
élection les cassettes vidéo les albums
photos les chartes de première dauphines
et du coup quand j'étais petite j'ai
grandi en fait dans cet univers parce
que j'ai toujours voulu faire quand même
et après à 13 ans le président du Comité
Miss Bastia qui est le chef-lieu de la
Guadeloupe m'a repéré il a dit à ma mère
dans 5 ans elle revient donc après il a
envoyé des messages à ma mère il lui a
dit bon
je crois qu'elle se présente je me suis
présentée à l'élection Miss Basters et
après du coup comme la miss Bastia se
présente à l'élection de Miss Guadeloupe
ça a été une continuité
je pense que vous allez marquer
l'histoire des
travailleurs ou le discours mon discours
je l'avais préparé ça faisait déjà un
mois ou pas
ma mère a
vu le temps mais c'est vrai que c'était
avec des coachs plutôt
un peu contre ça
et on le dit à chaque fois du naturel il
faut rester naturel
[Musique]
cité et ce qui est important aussi c'est
plus naturel et toi tu as été là
mais il faut faire attention à ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est stressant
en fait j'ai pas du tout stressé le soir
du prime pas du tout vraiment pas du
tout quoi tout a glisser comme ça direct
je vais pas refaire le problème de Miss
France donc on profite pleinement
quand tu as un peu plus compliqué non
mais bon la mais encore ma gueule
je vais te dire donc
et tu
en couple
il sait tout
mon cœur appartient à tous les Français
ah ça c'est ce que lui
on leur dit de dire ça on leur dit de
dire mon cœur appartient à tous les
Français alors même pas bah c'est ce que
disait il y a de l'air aussi
voilà on ne dit pas de le dire mais j'ai
envie de le dire mais je suis en couple
parce que vous n'êtes pas encore non
disponible pas disponible c'est-à-dire
son carré
je me consacre pleinement
toutes les interviews a été génial et là
ça part en cacahuète
[Musique]
Tarik merci d'être là merci à vous ça a
été la nuit l'été parce que si on s'est
vu hier soir ça va très bien
comme tu as vu ma gueule ça a été quand
même j'aimerais que tu nous racontes qui
s'est passé il est 19h je vais te
tutoyer
tu déposes tes enfants à l'entraînement
de foot et la glace
donc je dépose mes enfants en train de
foot et puis après comme j'avais une
heure devant moi j'ai décidé d'aller
faire des petites courses à Lidl donc je
fais mes courses normalement dans le
magasin j'arrive à la caisse il y a
trois personnes qui se sont fait
agresser d'ailleurs à ma place du moins
j'aurais dû être à leur place donc ils
m'ont laissé gentiment passer parce que
j'avais que 3 articles et puis arrivé à
la caisse quand j'ai payé mes articles
j'ai entendu des cris moi je pensais que
c'était une bagarre donc j'ai mis deux
trois secondes à réaliser que en fait
voilà c'était un homme qui a agressé des
gens avec deux armes blanches donc il
avait une arme dans chaque main donc
j'ai mis deux trois secondes quand j'ai
vu du sang quand j'ai vu du sang j'ai
compris que il y avait quelque chose de
grave donc il y avait une cliente
forcément donc exactement il y avait une
cliente juste avant moi qui a été avec
une petite fille donc qui a pris sa
fille qui s'est enfui parce que la porte
de sortie était juste à côté elle a
laissé son caddie en bas juste devant
moi et donc bah il fallait intervenir et
puis donc spontanément j'ai pris le
caddie pour remettre une distance entre
moi et lui il a quand même réussi
toucher à me toucher à la tête une
blessure superficielle puis comme il
avait deux armes donc après j'ai foncé
dessus avec le caddie et quand j'ai
voulu profiter du choc pour essayer de
lui sauter dessus pour pour le maîtriser
ou le mettre par terre ou faire quelque
chose c'est là qu'il m'a mis un deuxième
coup qui m'a tranché il m'a tranché de
doigts de doigts donc j'ai pu quand même
le pousser après j'ai couru à
l'intérieur du magasin j'ai glissé dans
une marre de sang j'ai paniqué parce que
je savais pas si me suivait ou pas donc
j'essayais de me relever tout en
regardant derrière moi et quand j'ai vu
qu'il bah en fait qu'il est parti dans
le fond du magasin c'est à ce moment là
qu'il a agressé la jeune la jeune fille
belge belge à ce moment-là et puis quand
je me suis relevé et ben là comme il est
parti dans le fond du magasin tous tous
les tous les tous les victimes qu'on
était à la caisse bah on a tous tous
pris bah voilà la sortie et puis et puis
aller se mettre à l'abri le plus
rapidement possible vous êtes amputé de
de doigts est-ce que vous êtes pas dit
un moment il faudrait peut-être pas dû
j'aurais dû partir honnêtement si
c'était une arme à feu
je pense que
ma réaction aurait été différente mais
alors d'aujourd'hui quand je vois par
exemple mes je vois mes enfants j'ai
trois enfants je leur fais d'ailleurs
leur faire un gros bisou à mes enfants
que voilà ils disent que je suis un
héros quand on sort dans la rue ils
disent voilà c'est mon papa c'est le
héros donc voilà c'est aussi pour eux un
exemple voilà un exemple à suivre et
puis pour toute vous êtes un exemple
tous les jeunes et puis si demain voilà
si demain une agression une personne
assiste à une agression et il faut
absolument
intervenir parce que on peut pas laisser
faire comme ça des injustices
d'agressions
sans sans comment dire sans sans réagir
pour célébrer héros quand tes enfants
disent que tu as un héros moi je te le
dis tu as un vrai bonhomme parce que y
aller devant un hachoir moi j'aurais
peut-être fait comme toi une arme à feu
je me serais peut-être barrer un hachoir
j'aurais peut-être été mais c'est ce que
tu as fait c'est très fort ça c'est un
vrai bonhomme il en faut des mecs comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci pour la course merci pour le
spectacle
c'est monté trop vite
à ça quand tu es pas entouré ce que je
disais j'ai fait deux trois masterclass
là avec des jeunes et tout ça si c'est
pas entouré de ta famille
de gens solides autour de toi pas des tu
sais mieux que moi Cyril
tous les jours on envoie des
picassiettes des gens et si tu as pas
des vrais gens autour de toi tu montes
et tu pètes tout parce que ça va trop
vite ça monte d'un coup et moi je suis
monté super vite et d'un coup j'ai rien
compris et après tu écoutes pas vraiment
tout ça tu crois que ben non et puis tu
glisses beaucoup de jalousie aussi à
l'époque quand tu dis tu es monté hyper
vite quoi les gens étaient jaloux les
gens étaient aussi ouais c'est quoi tu
avais des mecs qui fait des nouveaux
amis toi tu fais des jaloux je veux dire
quand tu as des succès tu jalouses les
gens en France en France contrairement à
d'autres pays
on le succès il fait on jalousie
et puis et puis si tu dérapes nous en
plus
des origines qu'on a on a moins le droit
à l'erreur qu'aux autres on doit être
vraiment irréprochable et si tu fais une
boulette toi il faut que il faut que
vraiment tu fasses attention un autre
qui va être qui va pas avoir les mêmes
origines que toi il va faire une
boulette bon ça va pas être pris pareil
on va essayer de l'effacer un petit peu
on va pas citer de Blaze mais voilà et
aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est quoi
c'est le professionnelisme tu crois
aujourd'hui je fais des acteurs qui ont
fait qui ont fait des des erreurs mais
qui ont été moins voilà bien sûr bien
sûr on va pas citer non mais bien sûr
ceux qui reviennent
et qui m'ont fait du mal avant
je travaillerai pas avec eux je leur
ferai rappeler en tous les cas au moment
où j'ai eu besoin de toi je m'attendu la
main là tu as besoin de moi je vais pas
venir j'ai un ami avec moi on a trouvé
encore comme je me répète un petit peu
on a des gens des chefs d'entreprise qui
mis sur sa Mina série qui aime la
mentalité de Samy nacirine l'écriture de
Bibi Naceri et donc ces gens-là c'est ce
qu'on grandit avec les taxis là on vient
de produire Eric vient de produire on a
on a tout produit tout seul on s'est
autoproduit on n'a rien demandé ni CNC
ni aide à l'écriture on aurait pu le
faire peut-être même me le redonner mais
on voulait pas perdre de temps voilà
quoi je veux dire
je fais les choses tout seul ceux qui
vont venir et qui n'auront pas fait de
mal dans les acceptera volontiers et
puis ceux qui étaient pas là quand
j'avais besoin d'eux et qui m'ont pas
tendu la main qui m'ont plutôt écrasé
ben on leur dira non désolé vous étiez
pas là quand on avait besoin de VOUS
j'ai un grand regret ça c'est quoi
mon plus grand regret c'est peut-être
d'avoir pas rester dans les clous
ou j'aurais dû rester dans les clous et
c'est tout traversé dans les clous et je
me suis dit j'en ai rien à [ __ ] parce
que je suis bon et que les gens ils me
font travailler je faisais 4 films 4
films par an c'est quoi la plus grosse
folie que vous avez faite quand vous
allez toucher vos premiers gros cachets
m'a permis d'acheter un appartement
à Boulogne en face du bois que j'ai tout
cassé le temps non merde j'ai fait des
travaux mais tu étais pas là sinon je te
rappelle bah oui et ça a été en face du
bois de la Folie c'est d'acheter mon
premier appartement et c'est bien ça bah
c'est bien oui c'est pas une folie non
une fois bah si c'est une folie pour moi
faisait tous les soirs ça
[Musique]
s'appellera pendant un an pantine nous
rajouterons un e au nom de la ville
c'est quoi cette darka là et les mecs
ils sont devenus fous franchement c'est
quoi la question une bonne démarche qui
dit oui donc comment tu dis oui on sait
que voilà ça part en cacahuète Mathieu
qu'est-ce que tu en penses c'est
ridicule c'est c'est grotesque c'est
d'autant plus grotesque encore une fois
c'est pas les mots qui comptent c'est
les actes voilà là c'est un mot pour
team il va rien se passer c'est de la
com ce qui compte c'est les actes et
uniquement les actes fois mon amour
comme dans tout d'ailleurs le reste
c'est des mots donc évidemment ça va
plaire à agile c'est un symbole à la con
c'est grotesques
franchement c'est formidable comme
initiative c'est contre les violences
faites aux femmes c'est pour l'égalité
homme voilà ma mère qui agit elle mérite
mieux qu'un coup de comète elle mérite
beaucoup mieux qu'un jour
ce n'est pas un coup de comme c'est un
symbole c'est un truc c'est pour attirer
l'attention regardez on en parle et
c'est légitime il faudrait que toutes
les villes parce que c'est ridicule
toutes les villes sont rebaptisées
toutes les villes pour manger une ville
est masculine ou féminine Paris c'est
masculin ou féminin enfin ça n'a aucun
sens donc c'est une mesure tiède qui
sert à rien à part faire faire du buzz
pour le maire et lui faire gagner 3
abonnés sur Twitter et faire deux
articles sur melty buzz tout le monde
s'en fout ça vous ça vous dérange si
vous appelez Gilberte
c'est carrément contre-productif
regardez on est tous évidemment contre
les violences faites aux femmes mais on
est tous contre cette initiative donc
c'est du buzz négatif et c'est comme
pour l'écologie c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi et totalement contre-production
pour qu'on parle de lui parce que ça
amer d'une petite ville personne ne
connaît une petite fille pour moi ça
aurait été entendable j'aurais été
d'accord avec Gilles si la suite du
discours c'était et d'ailleurs j'ai créé
les structures pour accueillir les
femmes battues etc
il avait créé vraiment de des vraies
choses pour pallier à ça mais juste dire
qu'il a qu'il a changé le nom de la
ville
outre le fait que c'est un gadget et du
marketing et de la poudre aux yeux que
ça sert à rien alors je propose au maire
de pantine de faire un audit et de
savoir exactement combien il y a de viol
dans sa ville combien il y a d'agression
sexuelle combien il y a de femmes qui
sont victimes de violences conjugales et
s'il y a une égalité des salaires entre
les hommes et les femmes si globalement
ça va changer entre janvier 2023 et
décembre 2023 et si ça a changé de
manière drastique et radicale là j'irai
ah ouais c'est vachement bien de
s'appeler penser mais sinon c'est du
bidon ça changera évidemment du rien du
tout
content de faire rien ici vous vous
plaignez qui est pas d'action et cetera
voilà un maire qui agit c'est pas une
accident mais arrêtez mais ouvrez un peu
les yeux circulez un peu regarder
tu as entendu
oh là là attention j'ai pas tous les
femmes
concret là-dedans c'est juste qu'il a
fait du cinéma en mettant un E qui
existera dans aucune connais le cinéma
il va changer aucune adresse il va
changer aucun panneau il est passé à la
télé ce soir il est content ça s'appelle
une prise de conscience
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]